Naturally, once you've initialized
a dictionary you're going to want
to add items to it.
To add a key value pair to a dictionary,
set the value for
the key using subscript syntax.
So here we'll add a couple of entries
to our animal groups dictionary.
A group of crows is called a murder.
I always thought that was a strange one.
And a group of monkeys
is called a troop.
If we use the count method, which has
the same syntax of the array classes
count method, we can see that before we
had three entries, but now we have five.
And if we print out the dictionary,
we can see the two new entries.
Removing a value from a dictionary
looks very similar to adding a value.
But in this case, the value for
the key is assigned to nil.
And after we assign the value for
crows to nil.
We can see that the crows murder pair
has been removed from the dictionary.
What if we want to change
the value associated with a key?
For this we have a couple options.
We can keep using the same versatile
subscript syntax like this.
Here, let's change troop to barrel, or
we could use the method update value for
key.
This method is interesting because
it returns an optional value.
This is good because if you try to
update a value that's not in your
dictionary.
Your program will crash.
The update value method will
just return nil And go ahead and
add the new key-value
pair to the dictionary.
And here you can see we've added a crash
of rhinoceros to our dictionary.
No pun intended, I swear.
If the dictionary does indeed contain
the value you tried to update,
the update value for
key method returns the former value.
The old value.
Like we saw here when
the method returned flock.
If you want to retrieve the value for
a particular key you can use,
you guessed it.
Sub script syntax.
In other words, the dictionary name
followed by the key in square brackets.
Let's scroll this up and
make a little more room.
One has to be careful when
retrieving values from dictionaries.
Because retrieving a value for
a given key from a dictionary
returns an optional.
Why would a dictionary
return an optional?
I'm just going to pause for
a few seconds and let you think.
It returns an optional because there's
always a chance that the key value pair
you're looking for
isn't in the dictionary.
There are many cases in which a program
might ask for a value from a dictionary,
not knowing whether it will be there or
not, so it returns an optional.
And naturally,
that optional needs to be unwrapped.
We unwrap a value returned from
a dictionary using if let,
just like we'd unwrap
any other optional.
In this example we want to retrieve
the value for a group of whales and
use that value in this print statement.
So we unwrap it like so.
And here the optional has a value, pod.
So what happens if the key isn't found?
No problem, we're covered.
Like in this example.
Sasquatches are not in our dictionary,
so the optional has a nil value.
But that's okay because we've specified
exactly what we want the program to do
in case of a nil value.